hallo zusammen meine liebe freunde wir
spielen heute twister
wenn man mal
redet zum ersten mal dabei kann man es
ja gerade noch in die kamera halten
gleich wie das mir so ein schwieriger
wenn mir verknotet sind du musst deinen
rechten fuß auf rot packen
das noch nie gespielt ehrlich gesagt
ich drehe zum ersten mal und meine
lieben freunde ich muss ein allererstes
meine linke hand auf geld packen kommt
auch blau das wird schon schwierig dass
die linke hand
[Musik]
der mega heiß und meine erste aktion in
der zweiten runde wird sein dass der
linke fuß
ich will dass er
irgendwann hast du ja aber viel irgendwo
da musst du ja auch ein ja aber jetzt du
bist einfach noch nicht gehen muss als
nächstes die linke dort packen das heißt
jetzt nicht auf umwegen doch noch was
warum
luca erst wenn du nicht weiter front axt
ich bin mit meiner hand jetzt nicht
werden
ok
da sind einfach die linie von twister
ist ja schon so häufig gespielt linke
doch der beim ersten kilometer
vor ich auch super werden so eine zweite
kamera perspektive der
[Musik]
linken hat mich gezwungen hier
einzufügen dass sie keine profis sondern
eine leistungsturnerin war
er doch mit meines lebens
ist der linken
ich dachte das macht spaß liga viel geld
so ich will frauen sind linker fuß
dort so
schlank dass ist es disqualifikationen
und dann ist da noch das einjährige
umzusetzen wenn man etwas machen was
genau es ist grün und gelb
ich halte mich doch jetzt fest und das
so zu machen ja
[Musik]
linken fuß so glauben die
amerikaner ist setzen wir die freude
sieht hält jetzt auf jeden fall regeln
und ich will
mich vielleicht auch nicht so weit
auseinander bleiben sollte und nicht auf
geld ich gehe ganz an den rand ist ich
fühle mich ein bisschen wie die
oberzicke
zu die rüstungen sich aus
erster hand auf
öffentliche schneiden würde
wahrscheinlich in den relativ wenig weiß
ist nicht
glaubwürdig linksfuß ausserordentliche
session
theoretisch
ja okay das ist nicht einfach
die finger von der wand ich warum ich
halte mein knie brechen aufgeben
ja was macht ihr denn soweit du weißt du
musst immer auf der gleichen farbe ist
schön dort recht auf der
[Musik]
premiere und auch eigentlich sind diese
frosch gerade die solvenz linke werde
der beste rechte fuß aufgestockt
also ist entschädigung gehören sie jetzt
so ein bisschen über aktuelle themen der
weltpolitik unterhalten grinst wie ein
linker fast sein lieblings politiker in
deutschland
die politikerin
okay wer publizität politikerin besser
nicht mit politiker
weiß ich nicht so genau linke hat auf
grün denn das super diese zu fördern da
hat doch grün
diese festgenommen
drückt man doch meinen augen zu
ich habe schon geld habe ich das gericht
war zum dritten mal dieser wurde ich
will einfach nicht so langsam steht
nochmals hand gelegen habe sondern haben
hat es drum und da scheint es kann
ziemlich in die haut ein echter fuchs
habe habe ich werde jetzt mal schnell zu
ende bringen weil ich bin raus ich bin
die sommer ablösen ich will eins
hör auf mich anzustoßen linke hand
großer effekt
offenbar sehr 8 ist oben ich schöne
komplett leben echte doch geld ist ein
quatsch dass wir das weiter drehen
leichter haben auch geld okay das ist
jetzt so entspannt beim lieblings
position
auch
in cafés oft gelb sagte weiter auch
durch noch das weiß ich kann das weiß
ich ja
ok
entschuldigung an alle die ganzen gucken
aber
ich meine beiden töchter darunter war
schon immer egal
ich schlafe langsam eine überlegung wie
dieses video am montag
ja zunächst mal nach haben ganz unrecht
haben doch okay aber trocken jetzt sind
es
ok
[Musik]
auch vollkommen muss den rechten fuß auf
grün machen vor das wird weil sie werden
das sind
[Musik]
ein ganzes oft bei dir
gucken er wusste alles deshalb muss
jetzt ein linken fuß unter den
durchziehen
kann wer sich daran auch was ist das das
genommen
und roxel linker fuß auf grün
[Musik]
ok go
vegan als würde ich sagen wir dann eben
freude der bewohner hier wurde auf jeden
fall herausgefunden wenn es euch
gefallen hat das gerne ein daumen und
dem video darunter klickt auf die glocke
weitere spannende videos nicht verpassen
wollte